Oh, where am I?
Give me a sec.
Oh, there you are.
Everybody, hello, hello.
Before I say anything, I'm gonna boot up Neo3 right now
because we waited enough time.
We waited five hours for this game.
So I'm just gonna boot it up right now.
I don't know if sound...
Oh, so I'm still moving.
Ooh, that's awkward.
Give me a sec.
I should not be moving right now.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm zooming in.
Let me, let me fix this real quick, guys.
Like, I'll fix this.
Um, poop.
All right.
Sorry, I've been in, today's been really rough for my throat
today.
I've been coughing a lot today.
So, uh, today's a bad day for my cough.
Anyway, so legitimately, um, uh, yesterday, apparently for
those who didn't know, yesterday, uh, they changed the
release.
date and obviously I researched the release date before you
know before I make my schedule and on steam it was supposed
to release at 5 p.m.
PST on the fifth and then apparently 24 hours ago they
changed the release date to 9 p.m.
PST like just out of nowhere because on the steam it tells
you what time the release dates were and i even googled what
time does neo3 release and uh and then they were like
surprise we're gonna push it back a little bit to midnight
instead uh so uh so that's why uh so i was just like fuck it
i guess i guess more time to get some behind the scenes work
done i guess um because i was debating whether or not to do
the demo and then play the full game But I was a little like
paranoid.
I was just like, oh, what if the demo is a bit different
from the actual full game itself?
So I was like, oh my gosh, I'd rather just experience it
live of the actual game itself than go with the demo.
Because I don't know.
I don't know.
Like I looked at the demo seemed to have like 800 patch
notes every time they release a demo.
So I was just like, I didn't know.
And I did want it to stream today.
I still wanted to stream this.
I was just like, fuck it.
I'll just wait until 9 p.m.
to do the stream.
Late night stream today.
I don't know how long I'm going to be playing this game for.
It does.
It is a souls like.
I have never played the Neo series.
I have always wanted to play the Neo series.
So, you know, instead of starting from one, we're going to
go straight into three.
I hope that me not having any of the background knowledge
isn't going to fuck me over.
And they'll have a little small recap for me.
So I know what the fuck is going on.
Oh, shit, wait.
Wait, can I go back?
Wait, I won't.
No, I don't want to read.
It's 9 p.m.
Oh, that's so awkward.
Oh, that's awkward.
Okay, that's okay.
120.
I'll do 120.
Like, it's 60 is fine.
Actually, I don't know if it's fine.
Actually, I don't know.
It is a so-and-I don't really...
FPS dynamic.
To adjust.
up to the value set to maintain what the fuck what is that
what is FPS adjustment guys I've never heard of that before
what is that thing is I feel like this game is gonna fucking
kill my PC so that's why I'm willing to play on 60 frames
what is FPS dynamic adjustment I have never heard of this
setting before it makes the game looks worse if you lose we
turn that on or off i i've never i swear i've never seen
this setting before um no it says like well dynamic adjusts
up to a valid set in the fame rate cap to maintain
performance that makes zero sense to me uh like i'm sorry
but that doesn't make any sense like i don't know the way
they worded that makes no sense to me i'm like english
please english Speak English, please.
Jesus, Chris, why is there so many motion blur settings?
Motion quality.
Wait, that's not motion blur.
This is motion blur.
What the fuck is motion quality then?
Although, I think this is fine.
I have no idea what motion quality is, but apparently it's
different from motion blur.
So I hope that's all right.
All right, I think that should be good.
your controls i mean unless i i assume that because it is a
soul's leg i will not need to use mouse and keyboard because
i assume that screen shake turn that off i'm i'm sorry i'm
not a fan of screen shake uh in general standard i will have
bigger subtitles oh my gosh yeah bigger please
I saw somebody it kept showing up in my youtube shorts, but
someone was doing the they were doing a boxing build in
Elden Ring And they were literally like the control was
literally beating up a little boxing dummy It was actually
really fucking cool.
I was watching him fight millennia with the boxing with the
boxing setup is so cool like Like kicks would do one thing
like we boxed it you touched the tap top of the head it
heals It was actually crazy and it was like one shot to it's
like one of those builds where if you get hit once you're
fucked i think that's good save settings do you want to
finish configuring all right yeah sure hello whoa all right
like i said also i don't know sound i hope sound guy is
alive all right we're changing the english i'm oh you're so
oh my god he's naked look at the naked baby
I need a where the fuck is the audio there you go um where's
the subtitle is it in basic game settings excuse me where's
the excuse me I would like to set it in English I messed up
here
wait it was there it was in language oh my god I went I went
too fast subtitle skip cutscenes Oh, I passed it.
Was it an audio?
No.
Visuals?
Oh, my God.
Where was it?
Oh, language!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Alright, let's check this game out.
That's cute, though.
Not the... Okay, the eyes are a little bit too big on the
fucking...
Oh, my God.
Look at that baby's head.
That's like Jimmy Neutron shit.
Anyway, let's play the game.
Like I said, I hope me not knowing whatever...
What the fuck happened in Neo 1 or 2?
Um, isn't gonna fuck me over.
Shining stones imbued with human kinds, never-ending dreams.
Their radiance Harbors two kinds of power.
The first is that of total destruction.
Yeah, I hope like, story's not that important.
Oh.
The second is the power of rebirth that nurtures and heals
life.
Since time immemorial.
I mean, the fact that my skin suit isn't lagging like crazy
right now, that's a win in my book.
You know, usually a lot of games on launch.
The moment I booted up the game, like I'd be on like five
frames per second.
And the fact that I am not, I call that a win.
Like, this is my personal stress test.
Good sign so far.
The fact that I'm not five frames per second.
Brady, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just super as a pre-celebration of me asking my girlfriend
to marry me.
The ring is currently on the way.
Oh my god.
Congratulations, Brady.
says yes and then you should watch my stream right afterward
to celebrate thank you the stupid shot thank you thank you
oh that's cute that's cute okay
that that that little guy is really cute i like him are you
listening lord takachio you will become shogun soon huku
that's enough
also sound is all right so far lord kunimatsu i do like it
though you should buy a dog shirt to celebrate don't worry
they'll be back in two days if she says yes you should buy a
dog shirt in two days go to the mirror and get ready for
training oh is this a character customization why do i have
why do i have a towel on the mirror am i that ugly like
usually it's not a good i'm high like i'm like i don't want
to see myself why the fuck do i have Alright, let's make it.
Let's make us guys.
What kind of Shogun will you be?
Was the same appearance.
Changing would discard your current weight.
Yeah, yes please.
Oh!
So it's like male or female.
Alright, that's preset.
What the fuck is this?
Elbow and knee?
What's that even look like?
Oh, like if I've spread my legs or not.
gotta spread them wide gotta man spread all right yeah there
you go
let's have some scars i've seen some fucked up shit all
right there you go that stands up guys all right body time
not command the respect of the people i trust you have not
been neglecting your training the shorter we are the faster
we are guys you know how what they say.
The taller you are, the harder you fall.
Anyway, let's see.
We gotta be...
Alright.
I'm gonna make us, guys.
I'm gonna make you guys.
Alright.
And then, head size.
And then... We gotta make sure we don't get headshot.
We gotta reduce it.
Actually, no, that's... Never mind.
Never mind.
I think this is perfect, actually.
This is perfect.
Let's see.
Alright.
Let's be a Sigma male as well.
Oh yeah.
Actually.
We look better.
Smaller hitbox means.
Exactly.
Smaller hitbox means less damage.
Alright.
Okay.
We didn't practice our arm game.
But.
We did work on our legs.
It's alright.
Alright.
We worked on our leg game.
the guy from those mobiles but actually no actually i do
like i i do like the wide ass dorito shape i look like a
dorito wait muscle mass how do i know where the muscle is
can't tell our chest size is it oh i guess it does your your
the moves are a little bit bigger All right, here we go.
And then undergarment.
Whoa, wait.
Oh, yeah, there we go.
We gotta be cheeked up.
Want them to know.
Let's see.
There we go.
We gotta be cheeked up, guys.
If we have it, we gotta be able to flex it, you know?
What's this?
Oh, tattoo.
Oh, do we get a trap stamp?
Where do we put...
Where is that?
Oh.
On our belly button.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let's put a trap stamp in the back, too.
I don't have to move my... Okay, wait.
Back?
Alright, let's put the trap stamp behind us.
Oh, it has to be a flower.
That's the perfect stamp.
Alright, let's see.
Where is the... There we go.
Alright, here.
And then we'll...
Lower it?
Right here.
Not the trap staff.
Alright, here we go.
And then...
Ooh, it can make it shiny.
Wait, how does it...
How does that work?
It's a shine.
Alright, let's do that.
Unfortunately, I can't lower it.
I can't lower it anymore.
There we go.
I think that's perfect, honestly.
Alright.
Lower body marking.
Oh, it's for the legs.
Where is it, though?
Oh, it's right here.
They do say I don't know if you guys know this But I think
it's like an Asian What is the word called?
An Asian myth thing Where if you have a mole On any part of
your body And it's like a birthmark type mole That was how
you died in your previous life So We should add this And
then add it Let's see Let's see Wait, where is it?
Wait, where is it going?
All right, there we go.
We should have it.
I want to go higher, but it's not going higher.
Why is it?
Oh, shit.
Okay, never mind.
That's not where it's supposed to.
All right.
So we'll...
It's like...
Right?
They're not even going to be able to see this because it's
right here.
That's how you died in your previous life The weakest point
There we go Alright That's perfect Honestly perfect I think
like nobody can see it too That's the worst part But You are
to be on a proper show I don't know, I'm fine with this.
Unless we can...
Unless we can, like, have him start mugging, I guess.
Start mewing.
Like that.
Okay, this is, like, pretty...
Oh, there we go.
Yes!
Okay.
Oh, yes!
Here we go.
There we go.
And then...
Okay, not gonna lie, this is pretty...
Alright, there we go.
I think that's fine.
And then, aging.
We've all seen some shit, guys.
Wait, laugh, lie.
Alright.
There you go.
Honestly, I'm fine with whatever for this.
Oh, and this.
Actually, this is perfect.
And...
Honestly, I think we're done.
I don't think I need to do.
Oh, wait.
Eyes.
You're right.
Actually, I like the default eyes.
There we go.
Eye bag.
We've all...
We've all been there, bro.
We've all been there.
Okay.
Iris colors.
Green just like mine.
all right nose
honestly it's perfect oh teeth all right smile for me oh
maybe not
does it actually make it yellow no oh shit okay um maybe
don't smile for me maybe don't smile for me dragon it's okay
it's like everything Everything's fine.
Tiny mouth.
Oh, yeah.
Making tiny mouth.
For your tiny little bites.
Alright, how about that?
Oh, ear accessories.
Oh, we gotta get some ear.
Alright, nice.
Wait, this is like Majin Boo shit.
We can do a fusion with someone.
Actually, yeah, I want that.
This is like a little fusion.
A little fusion earring.
There you go.
Like a little fancy.
A little fancy dragon, too.
Alright, I think we're done.
Wait, flip horizontally?
Yeah, that's good.
What?
Oh, fuck!
There's more!
I didn't even notice.
Wait, actually, I don't...
I was like, oh, I think we're done.
And then there was, like, more to...
I actually don't like the glasses.
I forgot.
There's, like, 20 more categories here.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Okay.
so much more.
Holy shit.
I was not expecting that.
Oh my god, we could be a Geisha.
Oh my god, we could be Dora.
We could be, guys, we could be Dora the Explorer.
Dora.
Actually, I sort of want to be Dora right now.
Oh wait, there's a bug.
Okay, not gonna last, I really want to be...
I can't believe Dora.
I can't do any of that.
You know, it's fine.
Hair style, hair color.
Honestly?
I'm following my heart.
Hair tip.
Yes.
Oh my god.
I can't believe Dora.
Dora is a dragon.
Dora.
Dora, Dora, Dora, Dora.
Dora, Dora, Dora.
all right the rest of you was as imposing as your beard i
cannot help but record lord iyasa all right we should have a
little cute mustache for dora actually oh yeah that works
curliness does that actually work no it doesn't i was glad
to i actually like the default all right makeup time oh my
god there's so much you can do.
I swear to God, if I log, if we, oh wait, R2?
Oh wait, I forgot.
I swear to God, if I go in and then if I go in and then they
give me a fucking helmet, I swear after everything I've
done, and they give me a goddamn helmet after all this work,
I worked so hard making you guys beautiful.
I worked so fucking hard to make you beautiful, Dragon.
No way.
Glossiness.
There you go.
And then...
Oh, we gotta have nail polish, though.
We have to.
I think black would look great on you guys.
And then, oh my god, tone.
Yes, absolutely.
Alright, facial marking.
No, it's fine.
Alright, there you go.
And then, voice.
Am I supposed to know what he says?
Oh.
All right, there you go.
All right, I think we're good.
All right.
Finalize.
Welcome, Dora the Dragoon.
You shall be my chosen one.
Finalize.
Yes!
Dora the Dragoon.
You shall be my chosen representative.
You shall be my champion.
My tribute.
And then I hide the mirror again because I'm like, I'm so
ugly.
You're not ugly, daughter.
You're beautiful.
Look at you.
Don't hide the mirror.
Accept who you are.
That's the end of the cut.
No case.
X-Factor.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's go.
All right.
Let's head to the dojo.
Objectives will appear as white marks on the compass at the
top right of the screen.
The variant of the compass can be set in the basic game
settings.
I fell in.
Thank you for that five gifted ships.
Thank you.
All right.
It looks like he'd yell at me at Chai in his skill.
Thank you.
Let's reach out.
rise of a new shogun he used to be so small and sickly he's
like why are you still why are you so yellow now lord moni
nolly is waiting in the back all right speak to yeah you
mininori you've arrived hello all right hurry up and choose
a weapon to practice with all right where's the weapon oh is
it back here dual swords sword i assume that dual sword
odachi what the fuck is that's just a pull i assume a dual
sword would be like super slow but we'll try it out any
weapon will serve you in battles so long i feel like it
first focus on choosing something that you feel comfortable
all right let's try the normal sword oh is odachi a very
long katana choose carefully i don't know i feel like the
basic would just be regular sort Oh, that is a long ass.
Oh, it's like a giant sword.
I don't know.
I love dual swords in general in, like, these types of
games.
But their damage is so weak in general.
So I don't know if it's worth it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that strong attack looks sick as hell.
Yeah.
All right, what is the...
Oh, I think I'm going to do it.
I'm going to go do it.
dual sword first.
We're opponents.
Balance and easy to use.
Alright, we're gonna try a dual sword.
Check the spear?
I fucking hate spears, but I'll check it.
I don't like using spears in general.
Like, I never liked spears as weapons.
Yeah, it's spears pretty strong.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
Yes.
So that's the weapon you've chosen?
I would like to use my dual sword.
Yes!
I don't want to go slashy, slashy, but multiple slashes.
Then I'll choose this one.
I swear to God, this is like Pokemon where he chooses the
one that counters me.
I swear to fucking God.
This is why you never pick first.
You just counter pick the other.
Let us begin the bout.
Bout to each other.
Oh.
Gesture R1 and to open the gesture.
R1 one oh bring it on otherwise you'll miss all right direct
your attention to lord come on and then oh lock on oh all
right the ceremony may be soon but i won't be holding back
okay quick attack stronger now you'll focus on it quick
attacks all right first while strong That's okay, right?
Remember that.
Come on, fight back!
Fight back!
What are you doing?
Performing a key pulse after an attack.
Allows you to quickly recover key.
All right.
Before a key pulse on a tower, recover a portion.
After performing, press R1 as blue lights scatter around
you?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, okay.
all right I'll try remember that okay oh my god that sounds
like only Musha like the with a slash when I hit it I not do
it correctly no bad wait what all right that's right oh you
missed stupid I'm trying to Come on, hit me.
That's right.
Come on, hit me.
What are you?
A pussy?
Come on.
All right, I'm done.
The more you attack.
No, they give it a super chat.
Thank you.
It was my birthday yesterday.
And I was wondering if I could get a happy birthday for my
favorite yellow bird.
Please, because it's pronounced like worry.
Of course.
Happy birthday.
Happy belated birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy belated birthday to it.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Alright, how do I do this now?
I'm gonna get so overwhelmed.
Oh, is it more so like, I got learned now?
And then...
Oh, okay.
That's looking right.
What you gonna do?
Nothing!
Okay.
Oh my god, you're so bad at this game.
You're like, you're the head of the house?
Look at you.
Slash, slash, slash!
Wait.
Why did I hit everything?
Okay, there you go.
Hold your skills in battle.
Unleash martial arts.
And then follow attacks with key pulses.
Alright, the controller seems simple enough.
I assume like, I feel like I have to upgrade it, like, so is
like, where I have to put it on stamina and shit.
Yeah, I gotta make sure my stamina is getting fucked over.
You mean today?
I'm gonna defeat you always.
Look at that.
Like, come on.
Fight back!
Oh my god, this is embarrassing now.
Can't even get a simpler hit.
Oh, like, come on, bro.
Oh my god.
You're just gonna let me...
charge oh here we go again oh oh oh my god lord goody monzu
you fight how did i lose to you ever it won't happen again
look at that might as well make me lord i'm gonna fuck your
wife too i guess who
going my wife now that is odd does anyone see that furry
behind him?
Oh, shit.
Of course, the moment I beat the lord, he loses his castle.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, what the fuck?
Come on.
We did it, Patrick.
We saved the city.
That's odd.
My village is on fire.
Oh, my God.
she'll be okay she's got a nice massage like that guy
literally slam dunked the woman
holy fuck
oh i was gonna say there's no fucking way that that arm was
able to block that fucking hammer why are you still here the
castle has fallen to yokai not the yokai i'll clear the way
escape underground
okay guys i think i need a real sword um i like how i like
how like they haven't given me a real sword after that too
oh never mind it's okay i just manifested a story it's fine
I don't think he knows that.
I'm a gamer.
Where do I go?
I guess this way.
That's where the death and destruction was.
So we go straight to that.
Oh wait, there's an item there.
Alright.
She's dead, so it's okay.
How could something like this come to pass?
On the day your new shogun was to be chosen.
Hello.
You must remain vigilant.
It's alright, I'll watch.
You act?
It's okay.
I can... Oh, nice.
Appreciate it.
Alright, it's okay.
Don't worry, I got the final blow!
Alright, enemy are born.
Human to your recovery speed is greatly while in the yokai
realm.
Successfully executing will cleanse and dispel.
Okay.
That seems easy, you know.
There we go.
Oh, shit!
That's a lot of them.
Okay.
Oh my god, these enemies definitely reminded me of Onimusha
in general
Yeah, oh shit it's a hit
Successfully blocked All right, slash
Hey guys, hey guys, I'm aggroing them help help I'm doing my
jump guys.
I'm aggroed guys Come on!
He's on me!
Oh my god.
I hope I block that All right, nice Oh, I finish it Press
triangle When the enemies is out of chi Okay, there you go.
Am I finishing?
Oh, that's my familiar Bad tick
Oh, that's cool.
I just have to, like, know when they have a...
When the chi is...
When your chi is, like, low.
So beautiful.
I keep actually pressing R1 instead of, swear.
Because of, Elden Ring.
It's because of, like, souls.
I was like, R1, R1!
Like, why am I not hitting him?
At once.
My father, Sekishusai, split a massive rock that a Tengu had
transformed into.
This episode of Dora Explorer is a little strange.
Now it's my turn!
Jesus Christ.
He did that with katana.
There's a well up ahead.
Just past the inner gate.
From there, you can escape underground.
Alright.
It is my duty to protect you from the yokai.
fret not i'll be along as soon as i'm done i see my thanks i
don't think he's coming back guys that's what they always
say they're like don't worry i'm just gonna distract him
i'll be right behind you but they're never right behind you
like he's definitely dead dead oh and he gave me his
familiar yeah i borrowed it Oh, no.
I don't think he's coming back, guys.
He gave me his pet dog.
That's never a good sign.
He was like, don't worry, you're just borrowing my dog.
What's this?
Recover your life?
However you return.
Oh, okay.
So this is our bonfire.
By a prey?
So all the enemies have respawned.
The yokai have already made it this far.
The castle doesn't stand a chance.
Don't worry, parts of the castle are still there.
I keep pressing circle to pick this up.
Nice thought we finally created a peaceful world.
Was it nothing more than a fleeting dream?
oh wait they're just fighting each other oh wait no that's
my teammate I was like oh wait why are the yokai fighting
each other I was like oh shit sorry that's just my teammate
he looked like a yokai I couldn't tell he was camouflage
with the ninja gear all right nice even us ninja have been
pushed to the very brink no one can tell what the future
will hold for us.
Let's go over some of the ninja techniques.
Don't worry, they'll make a Neo 4.
Don't worry.
I know everything will be fine because I know they'll make a
Neo 4.
Use shift style.
Focus on direct mint and aims to dish out greater damage.
Focus on jelly combined with hit and run.
Wait, what is the ninja style?
Wait, I have to use my fist.
Wait, why would this be better?
Doesn't look like you have a weapon.
for a ninja yeah i guess there's no way around it get a
weapon from one of my fallen men around here let me know uh
i'll grab oh i'll grab the sword for ninja style just for
diversity oh wait there's hatchets oh my god wait wait this
is the inuyasha thing i know this wait i should want to use
this because This is from Inuyasha.
I know this from Inuyasha.
From the...
From the little brother that keeps dying.
Is that the weapon you'd like?
Yes.
Alright.
Get ready.
Yo-Kaiya.
Use the ninja's swift movements to confuse your opponent.
Oh yeah, I'm so fast in this one.
Oh shit!
Oh.
Using mist for intact?
Well, oh yeah, Kohaku, yeah!
I'm literally Kohaku right now.
Oh my god, there's a lot.
I'm a little confused.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna use my swing.
Oh, I do not have a lot of stamina though.
Oh, shit!
Nice.
Oh, finish it!
That's right.
Get finished.
Oh, fuck, there's more.
Okay.
I think, like, I don't recover the thing here.
R1 Triangle Square.
What?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm in just doing right now.
What the fuck am I doing?
Oh my god.
How the fuck did I do that?
What?
How come I can't do the...
Wait, I'm trying to do the...
The fireball!
Oh, I don't have any more.
Unfortunately, I don't have any more.
I used it all up.
attack is also vulnerable.
Use that opening to your advantage and counter-attack.
Okay.
How about counter-attack?
Oh, shit!
Now is the time for records.
Okay, like, you could have explained that before!
Oh, my!
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
It's fine.
I'm learning.
They didn't teach me to heal yet, guys.
I don't know how to heal.
Oh my god, I have to redo this.
Well, now I know how to play.
It's okay, it's okay.
I figured it out.
Alright, here we go.
Sorry, I figured it out.
Where is my... Alright, here we go.
Get ready.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Oh, it's like a little dodge shit.
Like after I attack.
If I time it correctly.
I don't know if I like the ninja move.
Not gonna lie.
I'm not a huge fan of the ninja form in general.
I think I like the...
I personally like the samurai form more.
Papa!
of your ninjutsu too.
Keep your distance from enemies.
Fireball!
Yeah, I assume I'll definitely get used to it, but I
personally, at this time, I definitely like, uh...
I definitely like, uh...
Okay, this is fine.
There we go.
Fireball!
Jesus Christ, how much HP do you have?
All right, there you go An enemy unleashing a powerful
attack Is also vulnerable Oh, fuck
Okay, you haven't done it yet Boom, I didn't time it
Okay, holy fuck Okay, this is I heal
Jesus Jesus Christ Okay, did I swap it correctly?
Swap!
Oh my god, I'm trying!
Oh!
Get up!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I did it.
I did it.
I timed it.
Okay.
I figured it out.
I figured it out I figured it out.
It only took me a bit.
It took me a while.
Swap.
There you go.
And I have fireball and I have fireball and I have fireball
and I have fireball.
Okay.
Fireball, please.
Okay, we figured it out.
It just took me three.
heels it just took me three all right never mind this game
is a lot harder next okay the scheme is actually a lot
harder than i thought i'm getting used to the controls very
slowly i sense the a bit messy but i got it was just a
little bit messy i figured it out you won't be able to stop
the yokai in that state least of all on your own i will
remain here and defend the castle with you taketio will be
fine alone have trust in your lord but there is no time to
debate the matter where is my food here i'll go lower the
ladder my polka my polka is here all right i deserve a
burger after that music i'm gonna grab my burger
so far my personal opinion about this game is that the
combat feels weird.
It's, I guess it's like how Neo is supposed to be played,
but it, it's, it is a little complicated and it feels a
little weird.
No, it's outside my door.
My PC is next, it's next to the door.
My PC room is next to my apartment door.
As they got up, open the door, grab the burger.
hmm don't worry it gets more okay I didn't I think what
throws me off is the the cheap pulses shit don't forget the
ninja skills you have learned that throws me off a lot stop
talking cat oh shit how many furries are coming with me i
brought another guy guys i don't have enough food for all of
you guys do not worry about how so he has survived many
battles even without my aid is there like oh god oh god is
there okay there's a shrine thank god i was gonna save am i
like a zoo now like caretaker i'm gonna use the samurai i
like the samurai more
All right.
Slam dunk.
It's very fast-paced, though.
Why don't you dive right in?
Why does this sound so evil?
I thought we were, like, good friends.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right, we did it.
We did it.
It's all right.
Nothing to worry about.
Just a little flesh wound.
It's because he's British.
It's just... The combat is... It feels so weird.
I'm not used to this combat.
Spirit stones unleashed a terrible conflict upon this
country.
We mustn't allow them to be used.
Ever.
again he says as we've used them again oh create a barrier
quickly this way not kunimatsu wait is that what huh that
dog looks very evil wait he's evil it
was die for their lord and i saw it through that looks like
a very bad dog it is i who know not to take care of your
fucking dogs and get oh fuck the seat of shogun oh fuck i'm
not ready oh shit let's oh my god um oh my god Okay, give me
a sec.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
I don't think oh I don't think we're living this guys
Maybe it's scripted oh, yeah guys it was guys I it was
scripted I lost as fast as I could because I knew it was
scripted and it wasn't worth it guys
Let's finish this already
You wish to become Shokun that badly.
Go!
Oh no, lady, I just met.
Are you okay?
Maybe you don't want it enough.
What makes a Shokun anyway?
Lady, I don't even know where she came from.
What?
You can't answer.
You'll never answer.
understand what is that guy hello
what is this is this kusenagi's power all right where am I
it seems kusenagi has something to say oh
choose attire appropriate for a ninja who's a taraproper
samurai oh my god okay but then she looks pretty cute though
but i think i prefer a samurai more i shall follow the way
of samurai has changed yeah you're up too your wishes seem
to have brought out kusanagi's power you may have an innate
talent for connecting with guardian spirits and drawing out
their power Okay.
Need the area.
So is he stronger now?
So I have porn for Kusunagi and leave this place.
Yes.
What a curious place.
Perhaps we will have cause to return sometime.
Alright.
Leave the area.
I feel like a Pokemon trainer right now.
I'm collecting everybody's pokemon they're like don't worry
i'll be okay please look after my dog and i'll be like cool
you're gonna come back right and they never came back they
never came back guys now i have three dogs to look after
and one cat oh shit my lord is he a bad guy or Oh,
that's a very bad dog.
I have a feeling he's not a good guy.
I've already cut off that curse escape route.
After him.
Yes, sir.
Oh.
That one, that two, that three, that four.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're so beautiful, Adora.
Alright.
Those pennants bore the symbol of the Takeda army.
But they were defeated long ago.
Oh, what?
It's time traveled?
What a sinister light.
Kunimatsu was shrouded in the same glow.
Okay, so now I've time traveled.
I'm back in the past.
okay we'll grab this can I do anything I must be able to
upgrade stuff later oh look at the top hat equipment
equipped gear assigned and items assigned to shortcuts can
be selected via equipment press R3 to automatically select
equipment oh wait I pre-purchased the most expensive one so
that means do I have pay to win No!
Where's my pay to win loot?
I, to be, I did not.
I should have read, like, what it gave me.
Oh, there you go.
Fire damage reduction.
It's normally...
Oh, gotta grab it from the shrine.
Oh, okay.
So right now, they don't give it to me yet.
What else is here?
Memories.
Okay, that's just a tutorial.
And this is my mission.
Alright.
Do I have any?
Okay.
Yeah, probably later.
That appears to be the Tokugawa banner.
It seems we've been whisked away to somewhere else again.
I can't make sense of this.
Let us continue for now.
Wait, what?
All right, watch this.
Oh my god.
Oh, I hope this man did not have a family.
Holy shit.
Okay, that...
Wow.
Okay, that's a little bit too far.
I didn't even do that to the demons.
He's like...
No way, I might be able to do a sneak attack.
Yeah.
I had a feeling that it was like a tutorial for sneak
attack.
That's a nice backstab.
It's just the wind.
A very strong wind.
Oh, man.
So windy today.
Oh, shit.
Oh, oh, it's okay.
All right.
I got him.
Wind never changes.
I don't want to go this way.
There seems to be extra loot here.
This water is crazy.
Almost sounds like someone's dying.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, there you go.
God damn it, I keep pressing the circle.
Oh.
There's like new loot.
How's that?
Uh...
Under T, thank you for the raid.
Oh, you had a great stream.
Thank you.
I mean, it has more damage.
More damage means...
Oh!
More...
More numbers equals more damage.
Alright.
All right, what do you have?
Water.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there's more.
I didn't even see this.
Okay.
What did I grab?
Wait, is this a long sword?
That's what the odachi is, right?
All right, fuck that.
I don't like how slow that one is.
I'm gonna keep these two I don't like how slow this be like
the odachi weapon is so I'm just gonna go back to the dual
sword a clash between the Tokugawa and Decade of forces oh
shit I can hardly believe it it's unfathom babom
Fireball!
I should have saved my fireball.
What the fuck?
Oh my God, I thought I blocked it.
He just grabbed me.
Okay, I legit thought I could block that.
It's like...
It's not expecting that.
Wait.
I mean, defense is lower, so I feel like it should...
Alright.
Or he command grabbed me.
Does he know?
Oh, oh.
No one?
Just a little...
Whoa!
Okay.
That's right!
Samurai form!
Alright.
Thought I was just a little ninja.
Surprise!
Match the samurai.
Okay, this way is the right way.
Oh, no, he's got a spear.
What the fuck?
I can jump.
I was like, what?
He'll never expect this.
A single arrow to the head will kill most anything.
Oh.
Oh, I've got arrows.
R2 while holding L2.
Okay.
Do I already have it equipped?
I do.
Okay.
Hold L2, then press R2.
I swear to God, there's falloff.
What?
Okay.
What the fuck did I hit?
Where did the arrow go?
Where the fuck did the arrow go?
I liked how you looked at me.
He's like, what the fuck?
What happened to him?
him there we go just slowly walk over oh shit he actually
lived oh but i don't have enough arrows anymore that's fine
i'll just climb up they'll never expect me up here is he
gonna climb up oh he is like he's stupid
oh shit no i'm gonna fall off Alright.
Oh, shit!
You're still alive!
I'll grab that.
Okay, now I can go back.
And that win is crazy.
Whoops.
Where I can lead this.
I told you.
I can lead that shot.
Oh my god, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
He doesn't know!
Look at that.
That's right.
What you gotta do?
Oh, that's looking right.
Get back down those stairs.
I'm gonna climb up.
Fucking easy.
But he's still alive.
Alright, just one more hit.
He should be dead soon.
Flatter is mine.
He's king of the hill.
Alright, nice.
Oops.
Oh, so much loot now from that?
I don't want to use the sphere.
Ooh.
I don't understand.
Like, sort by level.
There we go.
Wait, which one did I equip?
Oh, this one.
Okay.
I was going to say, I feel like level would be best.
That damn right I have the hot ground.
There's throwing stones.
Guys are easy.
There are too many of them without reinforcements.
We're done for Okay, I see the shrine over there.
I shouldn't pray though I feel like if I pray
What the fuck
You're in that fucking nerve been in that corner Oh
Oh, no, that guy's a bad man.
Oh, that was a very bad man.
Oh, I don't think he was looting, guys.
I don't think that was looting.
Spirit Stone.
Grants 500.
Oh, throwing stones.
It's a rock.
This?
What does that do?
Oh, like, look.
Alright, I assume that way is the way to go for progress.
I'm just gonna check if there's anything interesting back
here.
Watch this.
That's right.
Your FPS VTuber right here.
She still got it.
Damn!
That's what, and that's how you lead your shots.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, I thought that was a person.
She still got it.
Not washed yet.
Just like my simulations.
I opened this chest.
Oh my god, look at all this free loot.
That people were just leaving behind.
All by itself.
out here and there was just no one there and they just left
all this free loot for me.
I don't think there is anything on top.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't see anything on the roofs.
Oh, blue loot?
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Blue loot!
Okay, weight is heavier, but I think I can still have...
I can still take it.
I want to keep my current, the duels thing.
Okay, 75?
Fuck it.
That's a normal sword, right?
Is that the normal katana?
Okay, normal katana.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, and then...
This is stronger.
I have this equipped already.
All right, am I over how much weight?
Okay, I still have enough.
Nice, I'm still pretty fast.
Yeah, I keep pressing circle.
God damn it.
Okay.
So keep pressing circle.
I don't think I need to pray, though.
Because, like, um...
I feel like...
Eh...
Fuck it.
Let's refresh everything.
Oh!
Never mind, I did have to pray.
Allows you to play completed missions or undertake battle
scroll exclusives?
An expanded tutorial mission can be played after starting
the game through battle scroll in the shrine menu okay why
get anything out of it oh change guardian spirit answer and
play your stats okay um well we only have one guardian
spirit okay this is my level up okay this is where i level
up my stats maybe which stat in which weapon attack all
greatly affects your life.
What's my heart?
Oh, affects T.
Oh, this is for recovery speed.
Okay.
Wait, what's the skill, intellect, magic?
Oh.
Alright.
What is the most important level up for stats in Neo, guys?
Oh,
shit.
I almost dropped my water, but which one is the most
important no clue okay guys there's three neos surely oh
wait what health i wait wait okay i was gonna say does a
change of i i'm gonna keep it balanced probably depends
experience equipment has stat requirements depends on the
build okay i'm gonna run
yes I was gonna say like okay this is like samurai alright
okay there we go I've currently have alright this is the
other dead guy this is the dead guy's spirit why would I
ever out equip my own spirit ice and organized items making
boons Oh shit, nice Yay, pay the win Yay Oh my god Oh my,
okay Nice I'll take those Alright, nice, alright Val choose
the mission Alright, let's Let's pay the win You're kind of
weapon new type The following weapon types have been added
Alright, cool I love pay to win Um Wait what Is that oh
that's like versus fist Infernal duel Alright we'll grab
Okay that's a long sword This is the regular Wait but it's
attack Power is lower It's rare but You're not even that
strong How do you level your Sword your stuff up
Punch weapon?
But how do you level it up?
Oh, I get that ability later.
I will try it out.
Okay, and then we'll put on our strong helmet.
Uh, we'll grab.
I wonder if there's, like, bonuses that we put on the full
set.
Or you're fine out now.
Oh, shit.
It's gold.
Wait, I'm just going to keep the gold one.
What the fuck?
Life recovery.
I like life recovery.
Faster movement.
You sound there are, but later.
Okay, so later I will have I'll have it.
Alright, let's make sure we can equip these two.
Oh, wait, that looks cool.
The Inferno Talons?
Oh, wait, but I want to use the Inferno Kuri Kusurigama.
Grab that.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh, my God.
It looks so fucking cool.
Not gonna lie.
I actually look so badass right now.
Wait, am I yellow weight?
Ooh, it's okay.
Everything will be fine.
I'm still, I'm, I'm still sort of okay.
speed but i look sick as hell though like look at this i'm
not rudder running that's so sick look takeda's forces are
moving towards the tokugawa camp is someone still fighting
there i'm down by you let's go what's this oh shit oh fuck i
was like what is you What is that?
Oh, it's like those little ghosts.
It's like those ghosts.
Okay, I got it actually.
Don't worry.
Fireball.
Oh, I...
Oh, I should start.
Oh, okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Don't worry.
Alright, there's fun.
wait he healed that's cheating all right there you go wait a
minute I didn't even
healed oh that's fucked up I didn't even heal oh my god I
fucked up the timing oh fuck okay I guess I heal now sorry I
guess I I'll heal okay there you go
Oh shit, what the fuck was that ring?
Oh fuck, okay, it's okay, it's okay, I messed up.
There we go.
He counted!
So yeah, I got another elixir.
So it's like I never died in the first place.
Offering an Ochiko Cup at, or some and forth.
Oh!
Our life-defeating enemies will diminish the battle spoils.
Okay, this is a call of friend.
Alright, so blue is call of friend.
Red is fight of friend.
Get over here.
Fight for me.
Well, I already fought, to be fair, so I don't even know if
there's anyone to fight right now.
I sort of already killed them, so I don't know.
It's really pointless here.
I guess we just lose.
I'll pray a little bit too.
Some invisitor has been unlocked.
This feature enables you to request help from select co-op
and the shrine.
Oh!
Wait, I can level up too!
Alright, let's grab stamina.
And I guess only stamina.
Alright, so I can technically incorporate of another player.
How do I do that?
Summon a visitor.
Seek help from other players online by offering your call to
your visitors will see... Oh, okay.
Alright.
Come.
Does anyone want to help me?
Wait, how do I...
Is that it?
Come.
Is anybody gonna answer my prayer?
Dragoons, I choose you.
No.
Anybody want to take a sip from my cup?
Yes.
Hello?
Anyone want to take a little sip from the offering I just
gave you guys?
Oh, wait.
Hulu has live has live sports.
Okay.
Hello, welcome.
Oh, oh, he left.
Oh, oh, my God.
She is stacked.
All right, fight him.
Fight this gap for me.
And I got gum jobs.
Hulu has live sports and gum jobs.
Oh, yeah, the Olympics are going on right now.
All right, fight him.
She left.
She took my cup and left.
what do you mean I swear to God if you leave gum jobs I
swear gum jobs fight them fight them yeah go gum jobs go I
can't believe it Hulu has live sports fucking left me
literally game over just to fucking let me look at her very
lovely personality by the way and then fucking left that's
crazy now they only delivered a message that's
insane.
Unsubscribing from who adds them speed.
Alright, I hope he's watching a sick-ass cutscene with me.
Oh, that's cutscene of sick, though.
I was just knocking.
expecting her to like take a sip from my fucking drink and
then just left be like sick thanks for the free alcohol I
feel like I was actually at a club bought her a drink and
then she left didn't even want to talk to me
dare defy me Yamagata the mightiest of takeda's crimson army
I don't think I know you.
Oh shit.
But I just, I don't know, my fucking familiar fucking time
travel with me.
Alright, gum jobs.
Go gum jobs, go!
Oh my god, I have that too.
Watch this.
Wait, that's my samurai.
Baba!
Ninja star!
I'm helping!
Okay, and now I don't have...
Okay, you aggro him!
You aggro him!
And then I help!
Boom!
There you go!
Look at that!
Alright, we do that again!
Okay.
Alright, your turn!
Oh shit!
That's fine.
Alright, you do your job?
Alright, that's good.
That's good.
You're aggro him?
Oh, nice.
Finish her.
Teamwork.
All right, your turn.
Your turn.
Summon Kusanagi?
What the fuck?
What is he doing?
I'm still...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my god.
Let the beast...
I let the beast out.
That's right.
I'll let the beast out.
out all right cool reset oh wait he's gone my gun drops left
me he got her loot and then fucking be like peace and let
the devil out are you okay one day you will stand in
takeda's way oh
shit i did it that'll be 20 dollars i am honda tada katsu
retainer of tokugawa oh it removes you when you beat a boss
oh i see i was gonna say tokugawa that's that could you to
think one you only wanted me for my boss, Luke.
Oh, there's his persona.
Um, your persona's trying to touch me.
Sir?
Takeda Shingen.
The peerless tiger of Kai.
Don't call it that.
Has finally aired his facts.
It's his exposition persona.
Yo-Kai have joined with the Red Horde and are mercilessly
crushing the Tokugawa army.
The fans are relentless.
Also, for those who played a demo, has it been different
from the demo?
Or just the same?
The Red Horde's target goes without saying, Lord Yayas.
Since we were boys, We have fought countless battles in the
name of peace.
I will do anything to protect my lord.
It looks exactly the same.
God damn it.
I took the gamma.
Could have streamed at five.
I fell for it again.
Lorde Asus, Hamamatsu Castle lies ahead.
Mm-hmm.
No one pursues us.
But you are able to kill Yo-Kai.
Might you lend us your strength?
Also, I would be very freaked out if I see a guy in that
armor.
I'd be like, sir, your armor is fucking glowing.
You are not a normal person.
I wish you a safe journey.
Like, sir, why is your armor glowing blue?
Great military ambitions.
A sword, emmy, and constant thorn in the side in Obonaga.
Lumi for Historia de Japan.
Oh!
I know the Obonaga.
He's from Onimusha.
yeah oh my god i fucking stole his persona i stole another
persona why do i keep taking people's personas sharing my
lord's childhood name is quite the coincidence i have been
tasked with holding this position until my lord reaches
hamamatsu castle join him and assist him in whatever way
possible it's like the pokemon coliseum i threw a shadow
well.
Not only, but other helpful information, such as location of
shrines and graves.
Alright, that's cool.
Alright, oh, I knew it.
I knew there was something over here.
There was, like, a little corner.
There's, like, you know, classic map design.
I'm going to my OC now.
Alright, map to view.
Okay.
This is not a very informative I'm sorry.
This map looks so hard to look at.
Ooh.
Okay, wait.
Oh, wait.
Actually, that's 41.
This is still stronger.
I mean, it is gold, though.
Iron Switchclav?
What the fuck is this?
Holy shit.
Wait, this shit is...
Wait, I should like this.
This is...
blue is better than yellow the fuck since when wait blue is
better than yellow but it's gold what that does not make
that that rarity does not make sense i'm sorry like excuse
me when did when did blue became better than yellow
all right 68 base defense up
It's white, yellow, blue, purple, green is the...
Oh my god.
Wait, is green actually the best?
Okay, story by...
Level.
Oh my, this is like backwards rarity.
This makes my brain hurt.
It's like actual backwards day rarity.
Great, hello.
I'm out.
That's fine.
It's fine.
But now I'm so...
I'm so strong now.
Okay, so blue is better, but then this has more defense.
Okay, and then I'll swap that.
Because this is level 8, so it should be better.
And then we'll grab the Crimson Lombow here.
Oh!
No, I think our current thing is better.
Okay.
oh my god i don't think i like the cat he's quite good i
think i know why the other get the master the old master
that gave him to me he didn't want to follow him to the
afterlife you knew what was gonna happen and that's why he's
like i can't have this cat follow me to my death the cat is
a little annoying he's like a little navi this game is so
backwards for rarity it's like it goes everything I've ever
learned about rarity colors.
The fact that green is the rarest is fucking with my head
right now.
I'm like, green is common!
Green has always been common!
What do you mean green is high?
You can change the colors.
Oh, thank God.
That's good.
That's good that you can't change the colors.
That actually makes no sense to me.
The fact that gold is below blue and green is the rears
oh shit oh i fucking finished a tutorial guys does anyone
else see like hands coming up from the sky that grotesque
creature blotting out the sky it resembles the one we saw in
edo and there's hamamatsu castle beside it i am not Fond of
the idea, but I suppose we ought to take a closer look at
what they go towards the sky The fucking hands coming over
in the sky.
All right A lot of dead bodies.
It's not a good side If there's a lot of dead bodies, that
means there's something that killed all these people
point she is devoted to holding my skills with the blade
only to die without passing martial arts under my acquired
martial arts skills what the okay okay there's more stuff to
learn all right um all right i unlocked our samurai points
okay um well i should do that right what the oh my god oh my
god okay okay i can do this right oh okay all right okay
this is simple enough this part is simple i just need to
learn this stance oh okay all right i want for getting
attacked but by anything but a burst attack successfully
defecting attack well okay wait that That's cool.
That's parry.
I've been getting really good at parrying.
In general.
In God of War.
If you think about it.
Okay.
This is fine.
I'm not overwhelmed at all, guys.
I'm not overwhelmed at all.
This is fine.
Alright, let's pray here.
You may now fast travel.
Oh, okay.
We can finally fast travel, too.
Yeah, this game has skill trees.
And which allows you to progress with other players have
been...
Oh!
Alright, what should we get next, chat?
I get skill, right?
I should do skills because it helps.
Wait, what does it do?
Melee, attack, range...
Yeah, I'll do skill because it helps with, like...
guardian spirit.
All right.
I stole someone else's persona again.
I'm going to keep with my current.
I'm just going to keep with this one.
All right.
So now I
what?
What did I do?
Well, let's create a room.
Private.
You know what?
Let's explore together.
Let's figure this out together, guys.
All right.
Draft.
Oh.
How do I set up my Oh, six-digit code.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
All right.
Surely.
There we go.
Sure, why not?
Let's figure this game out together.
Let's...
Fuck it.
We might as well.
All right.
Where are my dragons at?
The most complicated password of all time.
We even have an enemy right here.
It's like Pokemans, for real.
It's so secret.
All right, let me...
I'll go...
I'll go stretch this guy up real quick.
All right, I'll wait.
Don't worry, the password is very easy.
It's 1 to 6.
No prep.
Yay!
Yay, Yager Storm!
Let's go!
Damn, you dressed...
Damn, you dressed like that?
You dressed like that for war?
Alright, go in there.
I believe in you.
I'm gonna see your technique.
I'm gonna see what your technique is here.
Oh!
Look at him go!
Holy shit!
Oh!
Okay, alright, taking notes.
I'm taking notes on your performance right now.
All right, nice.
I'm just evaluating his performance, guys.
I want to make sure that, you know, he's performing well in
my lobby.
How is he doing?
Wait, there's loot here.
I know, it's like a little test.
What's this?
Oh, there's a little cat!
I know.
Oh!
okay that's a bad cat that would be a scampus a cat like
yokai just like myself do I kill it more rotund than either
why don't you go ahead and give it a pet but what the fuck
is his purpose what is he supposed to do where is he taking
me oh my god oh my god he's trying to take me to fuck he's
trying to bait me this little fucker wait where do you go
oh hey all right all right now you're okay okay he got me
loot all right all this forgiven oh and i got ninja lock
nice oh shit they're like my little bodyguards let's go wait
this game is so easy wait wait because like i feel like in
elder ring enemies do not feel like they scale I will have
to say they do not feel like they scale to three players and
they're dying a little too fast not gonna lie so it's just
that easy guys just open up your your party and then send in
two Pokemans look at all these free loot
Ooh!
Free loot!
Nice.
Alright, we'll grab.
Ooh!
Items with powerful rare such can be attained from enemies
or chests.
Oh, what did I get?
Which one was that?
Okay, not that, obviously.
I got a rare item, but I don't know where it's from.
Which one was the rare item.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, which one do I have equipped?
I guess it's like, it gives me 75, 75 extra HP, yeah, but
but this one is 20.
Oh, wait.
Actually, this one 36, so I'll do that.
I get more HP from that.
And they're, like, very similar here.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go, my Pokemans.
Let's go.
Wait, I need to do that.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
Disappointing.
Timeout.
High five.
I got this.
Wait.
High five.
Hey, guys, don't leave me hanging, guys.
Come on.
Guys, don't leave me hanging.
Guys, come on.
Don't leave me hanging, guys.
High five.
Too slow.
Oh, wait, we did it still.
did it i was trying to make me like oh so all right where do
we go now i'm a little lost all right we go back i guess i
assume we go back i feel like this would this game seems
like a really fun uh would seem like a really fun co-op game
with friends especially it feels like because this feels
more The multiplayer seems more fun compared to Soul's Day,
I feel.
I feel like the multiplayer in this seems more fun with your
friends.
Oh, that's a big boss.
We would definitely take him.
And by we, I mean you guys.
All right, go.
I'll watch from here.
All right.
Go, guys.
Evaluating your performance.
Don't worry.
Here.
I'll give you guys motivation.
Watch this.
I'll give you guys motivation, guys.
Don't worry.
You guys got this.
I believe.
I'm role-playing as the Lord.
Come on.
Come on, guys.
I believe in you guys.
You guys got this.
Look.
I'll watch from here.
You don't...
I'm playing the game!
I am a supervisor.
Come on, Red.
Come on.
Your buddies already...
Your fellow co-workers are already heading over.
I'm a supervisor making sure they're doing a good job.
The more I'll get closer with you guys.
For free.
Don't...
where Red's coming over to help, dude.
He's almost there, Jaeger.
He's almost there.
Alright.
There he is.
You guys got this.
Hey, free look.
Look at that.
I believe.
Oh my God.
You're doing so good, guys.
Whoa.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll help out.
And then I'll boom.
There we go.
Never said I didn't help out guys Look at that.
You're welcome, everyone Look at all that loot just lying
here Look at all that loot just lying here So brave toky, I
know I sacrificed my as a leader I sacrificed my life to
help out Oh, what's that?
Why is that guy just standing there?
Oh.
That's right.
Go.
Go, my fellow Pokemans.
I started the fight.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck was that?
All right, nice.
No surprises here.
Oh, my God.
There was a surprise here.
All right.
No.
No surprises here.
Leave it from behind.
Look at that.
I frontlined today.
Wow, this game is pretty easy now that I figured it out.
Guys, now that it feels...
Okay, not gonna lie, it feels very monster hunter-y now that
I fucking invited people into my lobby.
I feel like I'm playing monster hunter now.
It kind of does, yeah.
I feel like, I feel like I'm playing Monster Hunter.
Things like that.
It's less souls-like, and more like I'm hunting your cat.
Oh, you guys see that?
Horizon?
Horizon, what was it called?
That Horizon series is releasing your Monster Hunter.
type game where they hunt mecca animals all right let's pray
i'm praying here i need to upgrade oh i learned new stuff
i'll do health again oh i can do health and i'll do stamina
that's health right constitution yeah yeah horizon zero done
they're unshakable oh i mean sure that seems
I know I have like Yeah, there you go I don't know if it's
worth Using my points to upgrade Like weapons When I could
just upgrade like my ninja Skills God This is like path of
exile Right now This is like Oh, okay I'll grab that Okay
all right uh where do we go here is this a boss fight guys
i'm craving a boss fight no they're just regular people that
we can murder no they're just regular people hello guys we
expect to cater to invade at any moment so the gate is
closed is this guy okay we expect to kick okay we're not
allowed inside apparently Because they're scared of
invasion.
I mean, I'm here.
There's nothing that you're scared about.
Me and my Pokemans are here to save the day.
Alright.
Yay, free loot.
My god, that guy is so out of breath.
Yeah, he is so fucking out of breath, man.
He might need a...
I don't think samurai work is for him.
I assume we just go.
Let's just go this way.
Nice.
one lure.
Look, see, I helped.
Look at that, guys.
I contributed.
Ooh, that looks like a scary place.
Let's go there, dragoons.
Come on.
Let's go into the scary cave.
Let's go into the scary forest.
We're all clearly...
Oh.
Wait, guys?
Why, guys?
Guys, why?
No, no guys.
No, come on.
Get over here guys.
No.
No
What do you mean you can't come over here?
What do you mean?
No
I know what do you mean I can do it?
What do you mean?
What is this place?
It's a trap.
Wait, can I?
Oh, I can leave.
Okay, it's okay, guys.
I can just leave.
It's okay.
No fun allowed.
No, it's all right, guys.
We can do this another time.
We can do it another time.
Now, this is where their journey ends.
All right, all right, watch this.
They think I can't do this myself.
Watch.
this oh wait oh i brought them in that's right i brought
them in oh thank god oh thank god it's all right i forced
them into the scary room wait wait look at that watch this
i hope wait let me know there's arrows here
Oh, shit.
Wait, watch this.
Wait, where are they?
Okay, there you go.
Watch this.
Look, look, I'm helping.
Look at that.
Easy.
I need to have the auto pick up.
Look at that.
Whoa!
That's right.
I'm helping.
Oh, my God.
We did it, guys.
As a team.
All of us.
technically all me but you know as a humble leader i will i
will also redistribute the credit bam that's right as the
person who did the most stuff in this fight oh hey nice
you're helping all right we did it we did it guys i'm
helping that was great yeah is that really all you got god
that was so easy that was for babies at this point yay
teamwork see this is why i didn't play the demo did the demo
actually did the demo have this feature or was this like
full game oh should i learn another ninja lock see this is
why i waited yeah Wait, yes or no?
It wasn't a demo?
Oh, yeah, but like...
Oh, shit.
Final blow.
That's right.
Oh, I definitely didn't miss.
Demo had super rare drops.
I had guaranteed rare drops.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Wait, we can beat him up.
Guys!
Oh.
Oh shit, wait, where is he?
Okay, we gotta kill him first.
Alright, get over here, guys.
We're gonna surround him.
He thinks he could just be...
He thinks he can be an evil spirit in my world.
Alright, watch this, guys.
Alright, let's beat up this evil spirit together.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, that's right!
What are you gonna do about that, huh?
oh wait he's dead all right um that's awkward uh guys how do
i guys how do i stop how do i how do i sheep the furry get
ganged up on oh we should have all transformed there all
right nice i'm gonna grab this
Alright, nice.
Where else do we go?
This is very open world.
Oh, shit.
How did I...
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, I definitely need a heal, though.
It's full dog.
You cannot stop the furry.
It's very open world, for sure.
Because I don't know where to go.
I'm just going where my heart takes me.
but I gotta pray real quick here pray oh purified soul how
do I purify it oh I need to do all of that stuff to purify
it you have a soul core that can be set in your oh my god
there's still more stuff to learn there's so many things to
learn in this game.
I'm just going to balance everything out.
I'm way too confused on how to do my management for this.
Alright.
Should be good.
Do I need to do I need to put anything new on?
There must be a store where I can sell all of this.
Like, I have too much stuff on my inventory.
There must be a place to of my items.
There's just way too much shit right now.
Later on?
Okay, that's good to know.
Alright, where do we go, guys?
You know what?
Where's my compass say?
Alright, let's go over to the castle.
I'm heading straight there.
We don't even need a B here.
Alright, this is the door.
Let's head to the objective, guys.
Oh, hey, look.
Oh shit.
Hello.
That's awkward.
That's right.
We picked the wrong place!
That's looking right!
We picked the wrong place to drop down!
I can't even see what's going on!
That's right, we hugged you!
Oh my god, there is literally...
I don't think they scaled this.
I legitimately do not think they scaled the enemies.
They seem like the same HP as you were in your solo right
now.
Yeah, they can't even fight back.
Ah, guys.
Come on.
Come with me.
Just a little oversight.
You picked the wrong house.
I have two friends.
like hell itself damn that shingen
we would have thought they'd prevent a retreat to the castle
like that
i mean i would freak out oh his dog look oh his dog is so
cute wait i love his dog okay if i'm fucking adopting for
sojourners like i should be able to adopt that guy's dog is
this not the person mentioned by the messenger from
hittokoto slope earlier that's a cute ass dog takachio you
are the samurai who fells yokai yeah i'm gonna steal that
dog too i'm gonna be stealing people's dogs i want that dog
holy i want that tiger too i trust you'll be able to rid us
of this crucible
wait that tiger's sick this way i want that tiger too i will
guide you
or is she guiding me yeah i am i'm this is literally pokemon
right now i'm just collect gotta collect them all enter the
crucible holy that's a very evil wall that of the yokai none
who have entered have ever returned we call this a cursed
land the crucial I can't request help from this guy why is
there so many people asking for wanting to help that's I
don't know that's pretty suspicious look at all the live
people wanting that oh is this a store oh thank god okay i
should want to sell oh my god i don't even know what to sell
all right uh sort by rarity okay i'll just sell
wait what it's it's white it's in white like bad what wait i
feel like i don't need any of this
guys yeah but it's white is bad
can I just sell the white ones that's the lowest rarity
right just want to be sure before I sell it
I don't know if my chat died or nobody's yeah I'm selling
these I'm I'm just going to sell these then.
I was going to be like, guys.
Why is no one saying anything?
Okay, I'll sell these then.
I have way too many yellow and white equipment.
Alright.
Yes.
Sell all.
Oh, hope I didn't fuck up.
Hope I didn't fuck up there.
Alright, here you go.
Oh, I have this equipped.
Oh, shit.
It's fine, right?
Yes, yes.
Alright.
What do they give me?
Exchange.
Alright, let's go.
I finished talking to the evil baby.
Let's go in.
Alright, let's enter the crucible, guys.
Okay.
It seems a lot friendlier inside.
Oh, I get to pray.
Oh, this is the new shrine.
Okay.
This is what the new shrine looks like inside the...
I will say this place looks friendlier inside than outside.
The outside was pretty scary.
It looked pretty dangerous.
from the crucible I've never seen a loki like it before this
seemed too bad there's a lot of loot here a lot of loot here
no monsters what's there to worry about see it doesn't seem
like any monsters are around oh there you go all right it's
fine That gave me a shock was that Kusunagi's light.
All right, we got this guys.
Come on We're sorry.
All right, let's go Let's get let's fight.
Let's fuck him up.
Go in as a gang Yeah, wait, where's my gang?
All right, that's right.
Oh my god, that's fucked up and that Like all three of us
just went in here and pummeled that poor man Swarm him 3v1
Yeah, we fucking jumped that guy's ass
Alright, parkour attack Oh shit, oh fuck Guys Guys, no
Guys, someone Pick me up Pick me up Oh All right round two
That was planned guys not full HP I'm full HP now Look at
that I did that on purpose so now I'm full HP guys look I'm
helping
All right, let's help her Don't worry, I'm helping That's
right.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he hit me back.
Never had it happen before.
Never had someone hit me back before.
Alright, guys, guys.
We gotta let our wolves out.
Let our first show now.
Ready?
Are you guys ready?
Guys, are you guys ready?
Brent, come over here.
Alright.
The moment I do this, we let the beast out.
Let the beast out!
That's right!
Get him!
Alright, he's dead.
Alright, that was pretty easy.
We did it.
Alright, well, oh my god.
Look at all this loot, though.
He died.
Jump that dude.
He died so quickly.
I told you.
They definitely did not...
They did not scale the enemies at all.
And you literally just, if you have three, if you have two
friends, you can literally just zoom past every enemy.
I refuse to believe they scaled the enemies.
But now I'm just fucking casually walking past people.
The average souls game.
Oh my god.
It's going crazy.
Alright, you guys ready?
Alright, round two.
Round two, guys.
Get over here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Get over here, guys.
Let's got burn to death.
Stupid.
He's so stupid.
Look at him.
Imagine burning.
That's right.
Get him!
Imagine burning to death.
Couldn't be me.
All right.
Oh, you see that?
Okay, I still got hit, but like it was pretty cool though.
Wait.
Help.
Guys.
No.
How did this happen?
How did this?
Guys, who did that?
Okay, we can bone rush this.
I'm pretty sure.
Who let this happen?
I don't understand.
I thought we were invincible, guys.
Alright.
That's right.
I'm so angry.
agree.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I'm gonna take my anger out of this one guy.
Get over here, guys.
We gotta take our anger out of this one man.
That's right!
I'm so mad!
Alright, nice.
Okay, freestyle.
Alright, let's just zoom past.
Let's go.
Now that we know, we can walk past... Okay, I actually I
don't know about this guy.
I think we can walk past him.
Okay, give me a sec.
Actually, I need to heal.
I don't... Sorry, we can sunlock him!
That's right!
If we all keep hitting him, he can't...
He can't do any damage!
Okay, nice.
All right.
Let's go.
I think it was...
Wait, which way was it?
I'm a little lost.
Do you guys remember how to...
How to get over there?
Alright, it's this way.
Of course I remember.
I was just testing you guys.
Alright, we parkour here.
Alright, don't worry.
Oh, there's my soul!
Oh god, I got my soul.
I got my soul.
I got my soul!
It's fine!
Good.
I'm helping.
I'm helping don't worry firebomb firebomb firebomb firebomb.
Oh shit.
Oh shit Okay, I did not expect oh wait.
Oh, I got you Look at that I hope
Oh, yeah, we all live Okay, there is a guy up top.
So let me shoot him down real quick
Look at that You see that?
I helped my teammate.
I res'd her.
I am a good teammate.
I guess we go this way now.
And you want to loot this guy.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, I think it's this way.
What the fuck is that?
Get out of here.
Stupid archer?
Okay, it's this way.
Alright.
Let's kill this little flaming demon head.
Dixie can't run away from us.
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
I'm so tired!
Sorry, I need to up my stamina more.
Alright, this way.
Wait, which way?
I don't know which way to go.
This place is a little...
Oh.
There is this one guy here.
You know what?
Just to be sure, I'm just going to kill him.
Oh yeah, that's a lot of people.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I can help soon.
Watch this.
I let the beast out!
Where is he?
Boom!
Oh wait, he's already dead.
I mean, I'll kill him too.
Oh my god, we all let the beast out.
That's right.
You can go and do is throw a fucking rock at me.
Alright, nice.
Look, look, look, look, look, look.
Oh, oh, thank God.
We actually needed this so badly.
Alright, uh, strength.
Oh, wait.
Strength.
I'll just balance everything out.
And I'll...
All right, I'm level 10 now.
Isn't that this way?
Wait, which way would it be?
I feel like it wouldn't be that way.
Is it really that way?
I feel like it'd be in the creepy house over here.
I trust Jaeger.
This feels more like Endgame.
Oh my god!
Thank God.
Not me.
Oh my god.
What is he?
He's glowing red That's the color of evil
Is this way
My god, this fucking mosquitoes sinking fucking oh, oh,
that's a big guy I knocked I thought he was just part of the
background Oh, if we're such a big guy, he seems very weak.
Like, the mosquito has more HP.
I fucking...
Okay, it's okay.
I'm okay.
This feels like...
Okay, I will say...
The looting...
The looting for this game reminds me of Diablo.
That was...
I realize that's what it reminds me of.
It feels very Diablo-esque with how the looting works in
here.
Yeah, it's like Diablo, Monster Hunter, and Sword of
Souls-like when you're playing solo.
When you're playing solo, like when you're playing solo, I
guess it's Souls-like.
But then when you're playing with a group, it's just Monster
Hunter.
I want to enable auto-pick.
It's very annoying.
Well, I'm going to try that.
Where is it?
System.
Controls?
Six settings.
Where is it in the...
Where is it?
Is it in accessibility?
Game settings?
Okay.
Let's play it live.
Skip cutscenes, subtitles
Pick up over a drop Item, okay, there you go Yeah, I need
auto pickup I'm getting tired of Picking it up myself Like a
peasant I'm tired Like a fucking peasant Where's my auto
pickup?
There we go There we go No longer a peasant.
Oh, shit.
Okay, he's doing a lot of damage now.
I feel like I might need a...
I might actually change my loadout now.
Alright, give me a sec.
I have not changed my armor in a very long time.
I feel like my items are now a lot stronger.
Oh, shit.
Wooden hammer?
or what do i have equipped all right let's see oh wait 64
wait what would i have before 68 86 okay i know i think i
had all of okay 35
all right this one i'm ready i'm ready let's go it's hammer
time i think it's here oh i got
Wait, guys, guys, guys, I haven't prayed.
Guys, guys, I did it for...
Guys!
That's alright, I don't need to pray, right?
That'll be fine.
Oh, this happens a lot.
I thought it would be a little bit bigger just because of
the damage in this blade.
Alright, watch this.
I'm gonna slap that mosquito.
Okay.
Oh, alright.
I guess...
I guess he'll slap me.
Oh, there it is.
There's the eye.
I see it now.
No, guys, we can run all the way past this.
I'm tired.
Let's go.
Let's just speedrun to the end.
Watch this.
There we go.
We're practically here.
Wait, where is here?
Alright, we're practically here, guys.
We made it.
oh god wait oh my god fucked up he has a gun he has a gun we
gotta fight back now guys he has a gun what do we do i did
not anticipate man with guns
all right now now we run past everything now that we killed
the guy with the gun We can run through everything now.
It's just that easy.
Where is the eye?
Are we not here?
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
It's just that easy.
We go this way.
And then we go this way.
And then we run past him.
and now grab this loot and then we pray look at that we did
it guys we all made it oh nice we purified it all right and
then I guess I'll put more heart in here look at that guys
we all made it oh man this looks like a boss fight don't
worry We've all, we trained for this, guys.
By running away, we trained for this one moment in our
lives.
We can do it.
I know, why don't I have my own gun?
All I have is a stupid bow.
This looks like a boss door.
It really does.
I will say the character, the monster design is, I really
like the monster design for this.
game it's very creative
hear me out chat wait is that going to be oh he doesn't know
boom that's right that's my tank oh my god wait I can't be
spawned that's right
didn't expect this, did you?
Okay, he has a lot of HP, guys.
Holy fuck.
I am a little concerned.
He has a lot of HP.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my god.
I'm so EP.
Oh, my god, I'm so EP.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's okay.
Oh, guys, it's no longer okay.
Nice.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, it's okay.
We're fine.
We got him.
I'm monster hunting.
Oh, my God.
It's literally monster hunter.
I'm monster hunting real quick.
Okay, I'm getting backwards right now.
Don't worry, I'm ninja mode.
It's ninja time!
Shuriken, shuriken!
Firebomb, firebomb, firebomb, firebomb, firebomb, firebomb,
firebomb!
Oh my god, it's time.
We're doing it, guys!
Oh shit, I'm so tired.
I'm so eepy.
I saw me.
I saw my shuriken.
Nice.
We did it, guys.
Yeah!
We did it.
Quick carve her up.
Guys, we gotta carve her up, guys.
We gotta get the loot.
This would be so hard, so low.
Guys, come on.
To celebrate, everyone.
Who wants to give me a high five?
What?
Come on.
Who wants to get too slow?
New samurai monster hunter looks great.
Don't worry about this.
All right, who wants to give me a high five?
Come on.
Yeah?
Come on High five.
Come on.
I five.
You're mine.
I'm five.
You're mine
Too slow and
Don't trust it We did it guys we did okay.
It actually is crazy how different of a game it is come I
wanted to know How different the game is when you have
people just You would think it's skills, right?
Like, I know I keep saying that, but...
It's like an entire new...
It's an entirely different game.
It is very different.
Yeah.
It's no longer Souls-like.
I did it.
I saved the world.
I feel like I'm playing a hack and slash.
I feel like I'm playing Monster Hunter slash hack.
sack I
didn't think we'd meet again like this it's definitely feels
really fun what you're playing with your friends for sure
the light future versus time yeah it's just three friends
just jumping random guys but our meeting also pretends the
revival of a great evil that's confronting together you want
me oh my god my new persona yay I got a new persona soon
that other dog will be mine how long has it been how long
have I watched humanity's fortune have
continued to wield the benevolent blade
Yet my blade and mind were nearly destroyed with the
darkness is revived The light that can sever fate
Encountering the one who wields that sword has I feel like
I'm winning the joy once more I just beat up an old lady in
the corner Two of my friends that That ain't winning.
He's alive!
The battle rages yet.
Oh wait, no, it's time traveling so he has never died.
Wait, wait, this is some fucking paradox shit.
Intruding yokai have been dealt with.
Yeah, he's young.
Well done, Panzo.
I have returned.
You are unharmed.
Oh, it's him younger, too.
Quite superb, Takachio.
You would bear the hollyhop crest well.
There is much to discuss.
May we speak en route?
Alright, arm.
Oh, wait, is there more lore?
I was going to grab water.
Takachio.
Oh my god, this feels...
Now listen well.
This feels like that.
Okay, now we're in Dynasty Warriors territory.
Our base of operations for the whole Totomi region is under
siege from the north and east.
Now we're back to Dynasty Warriors.
Takeda Shingen leads a massive force that has swiftly
surrounded our forces in several locations.
Shingen.
I knew of his tactical brilliance, but for Yokai to be under
his command.
allies are being herded to their own graves but for a
warrior idly awaiting death is to disgrace your name for
generations i never played samurai warriors i assume it's
the same as the dynasty warriors one who has survived for
japan it's based in japan versus jano the time to venture
forth and test fate is at hand i shall make for the keep and
determine our plan of action Lord Naltura, wish to speak
with you.
Go to her.
All right, I ain't gotta pee and also grab water, so I'm
gonna be right back.
All right, all right, dragons, you two.
Red, digger, entertain my chat.
I'll be right back.
So what are you guys doing, huh?
What, what, what are you guys doing, huh?
Oh, you're gonna run away now.
I see.
Oh, I see.
Oh, yeah, you're gonna run away.
You're gonna be scattered.
Waiting for... Oh, my!
You have the power to traverse time and purify the crucible.
There is something I must share with you.
Hello?
Well then, shall we go?
All right, what's she gonna share with me?
The dark radiance that summons the Crucible is known as
Crucianite.
And those who imbue their guardian spirit with Crucianite
become immortal by feeding on spirit stones.
If that was the same radiance you saw, that must mean...
He won.
The one who's gutted Crucianite throughout time is the
source of this calamity.
Destroying the Crucianite in different ages.
Should we...
There's a shrine here.
All right, let's pray real quick.
All right.
One so, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I'm going to call it here.
Because I'm tired.
Personal opinion, honestly.
Um, it is seems really, it seems really fun.
I had a lot of fun playing with you guys here.
Um, but it does make it a different game i will say um yeah
i you know i didn't i didn't do a nap before the stream i
was just i went straight i i just did behind the scenes work
and then waited until the game
but it feels i didn't mention it before for this game or
watch the back flip while i explain I feel like Um If you
actually want to souls like You play solo But you want to
like Fuck around You play with a group of friends Because I
wanted to see what it was like I was like Oh I can invite
multiplayer Because I feel like Definitely for sure Um Like
Like Dark Souls Slash Elden Ring multiplayer Is a lot harder
Is a lot harder Than Where the fuck Neo 3 multiplayer Was
Yeah, but you want like a more like if you want something
more harder for yourself You want more challenge you play it
solo, but like for this I felt like It I felt like I was
playing monster hunter when I had like three people when I
had two other people join me That was literally just like
we're just jumping on the bosses and then beating the shit
up Yeah, it just felt like I just, we just like, we saw a
target and we all just, like, bash this guy's head in, like,
all three of us.
Because, like, enemies does not feel like it's scaled at
all.
Will I do a part two on stream?
Most likely not.
I feel like for the stream, I might play it off stream, but
I don't think I would do a on stream because i feel like uh
i feel like it would be more like a repeat of the same thing
where i mean unless i do a solo of course but i i felt like
the combat system itself for me was there's a lot especially
the skill tree the skill tree was was a lot for me and i've
never i've played Path of Exile before.
So I'm like really bad with skill trees because I'm like, I
don't know what to do.
There's no meta yet.
I don't know what that meta is.
Absol.
Thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you.
I would definitely play this off stream or like maybe I'll
do it a Twitch stream of this for sure.
I will definitely do like maybe if I want to like play
something on Twitch.
Like I just want something like a throw not throw.
I won't say throwaway game but more so like a game where I
could just like play on stream.
Like not have to worry about having a schedule or anything I
didn't play this on Twitch or like if I just want to play
something or like play something with you guys as well like
I just invite two random dragons or just play it off stream
with some friends yeah it seems like it feels a very brain
off type of game for sure um because I was not using my
brain when I was doing like I was like oh wait I can't have
my weapon out on this game because I guess like there's a
lady here um there's a there's a there's a uh get my weapon
up but i felt like i was like square square triangle
triangle r1 square triangle r1 square square square it's
just great off hit monster uh but it is fun it is a fun game
how to say it is like it is a fun game especially with
friends if you want to challenge you obviously you play it
solo and i it's still like the beginning i heard like neo as
a game is like really fucking long too i know neo 2 was like
what 30 the 40 hours long and i assume neo 3 is just as long
if not more um but that's my that's my only that's my i
guess like that's my review of the game so far Will I play
NEO 1 or 2?
I'm not sure.
Now that I played 3, I'm not sure if I'll play...
I guess, like, I went in thinking it was more Souls-like, I
guess.
Um, so, like, I personally, for me, um, I definitely, if I
had to rate all the Souls-like games I played, um, I think,
like, this would be, like, out of all the Souls-like games I
played, far, I would put this at the bottom because I, like,
you know, I played like Elden Ring, I played Dark Souls and
all that.
I, and like, I really like Wukon style of Souls, like, yeah.
I would like, I definitely prefer Wukon more, and, uh, I
prefer Wukon more, and I prefer, like, Elden Ring slash Dark
Souls more, and, you know, I like Bloodborne and everything.
Yeah, Wukon was really really fucking good um it i guess
like i went in thinking was more souls like than what it was
actually so like um so it was like a little bit like a jumps
not jumpscare was the way it's a little bit like oh i was
not expecting this you know type deal definitely different
expectations um lot in Elden Ring I I did enjoy the gameplay
a lot but this one it was like mixed for me um it was a bit
mixed for me because there was just so much stuff you know
it was like there was like different styles ninja mode
samurai mode and then the buttons are very weird I will say
like because like square the fact that it's like square and
triangle and not like r1 it like threw me off a lot because
i was i kept r1ning at first because i i was so used to
r1ning in all my games um i played lies of p i had i i
didn't finish it only because it's so it's so hard oh you
can change but the thing is like even if i change it i it's
just gonna it would feel confusing because i have to do i
have to make sure i press r1 to restore my chi and it was
just it was definitely a lot to learn in general like not
like not begin i feel like for me it was it didn't feel like
super beginner friendly And, like, also, there's so many
particles.
There were so many particles that I couldn't keep track of
when to, like, block.
Yeah, it's a lot of us to get used to.
So, definitely, like, this game took me a while to figure
out.
And it is, I will say, like, if you enjoy these types of
games, games.
I feel like it will it is like I don't think it's a bad
game.
I just think like I just think like I think I went in with a
different expectation on what I thought this game was going
to be and um and like it felt more like monster hunter to me
rather than like what I initially thought and I'm really
sorry I'm not a very I like I think I told you guys this
before Like, I'm not, like, a very Monster Hunter player.
I...
Like, it's not my type of game type deal.
Like, my type of game genre.
Yeah.
But, yeah, that's my honest opinion on it.
If you like...
I think if you like Monster Hunter, you would like playing
this with friends in general.
And, like, I think, like, if I play the solo...
the fucking combat was fucking me up a lot the only reason
why I was like I'm gonna open this party up I'm gonna open
this party up because the combat was fucking me up and I was
like fuck this
I was just like I'm gonna open I'm gonna explore with the
dragons because the combat oh yeah the combat um N7 they
give me the super chat thank you thank you Nokia dragoons
have the zoomies.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm just letting them tire themselves out right now I'm just
letting that's what you do when they have the zoomies.
Just let them run.
Let them run around and tire themselves out.
But yeah, anyway, anyway, we do have two streams tomorrow.
I mean, one is just an announcement stream for the
tournament, which will be revealing the teammates and
everything.
Um, and the other one is a member stream with men in black.
So it's very chill announcement stream will be a
multi-stream so i'll be streaming on youtube and twitch
since i was requested by um um by the devs of the game so
we're gonna it's gonna be on youtube and twitch and so i'm
gonna rest up now since i believe that stream is at 1 p.m i
believe uh so i'm gonna head off guys um as always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get
that blood flowing.
And if you set for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, my God.
We're getting closer to the anniversary stream.
Two more days.
I'm so excited.
Bye, everyone.
Bye-bye.